Born in Cincinnati, Ohio on May 18, 1915,
John R. Fox grew up in Ohio before attending
Wilberforce University, an African American
college located in a town of the same name.
He met his future wife, Arlene, there while
he studied biology and science.
The couple moved to Brockton, Massachusetts
after getting married, where they had a daughter,
Sandra.
At the age of 26, Fox joined the U.S. Army
at the end of February 1941 and graduated
from Infantry School at Fort Benning, Georgia
in August, not long before the Japanese attack
on Pearl Harbor in December of that year forced
the United States to enter World War II.
Three and a half years later, in December
of 1944, Lt. Fox found himself working as
a forward operator with the Cannon Company
of the 366th Infantry Regiment, the 92nd Infantry
Division.
He was stationed with his unit in the town
of Sommocolonia, Italy when German soldiers
disguised as civilians snuck into the town
on Christmas Day.
The German attack from the outside began at
4:00 am the morning of December 26th.
As for the enemy soldiers who’d infiltrated
the town the day before, they bolstered the
attack and, combined, the two groups managed
to quickly overwhelming the American soldiers.
However, when the outnumbered American soldiers
began their hasty retreat, Lt. Fox volunteered,
along with a few Italian soldiers, to remain
behind as eyes and ears in the town.
Fox’s job was to direct the artillery stationed
outside the town against the German troops
with the hope that it would slow their advance
long enough to allow for a safe retreat, and
re-formation outside of town.
So while the American soldiers retreated,
Lt. Fox stationed himself on the second floor
of a building in a spot that allowed him to
see the approaching enemy.
As the day, and the enemy soldiers, progressed,
Fox called for the artillery to aim shells
closer and closer to his position, matching
the German advance.
Finally, just before noon on December 26th,
Fox radioed into the Cannon Company’s command
post with the request that the artillery be
aimed squarely at his position.
The soldier manning the radio, Lt. Otis Zachary,
and his commanding officer then asked Fox
if he knew this strike would destroy Fox’s
position.
Fox’s reply was, “Fire it!”
Lt. Zachary then ordered the artillery to
“Converge, sheath.”
That instructed the soldiers manning the artillery
to direct their fire in a line, “walking”
it toward Fox’s position until they converged
on his building.
Zachary later said: “That was with high
explosive [shells], and that’s the last
I heard of John Fox.”
In the end, the attack forced the Germans
to delay their advance through the town.
The American soldiers then had time to reorganize
and launch a full-scale counterattack that
allowed them to retake the town from German
control.
When the soldiers went to recover Lt. Fox’s
body and the eight Italian soldiers who’d
been killed as well, they also found the bodies
of about 100 German soldiers around the wreckage.
For this selfless act of bravery, Lt. Fox’s
commanding officer nominated him for Distinguished
Service Cross.
However, the United States military overlooked
his sacrifice, much like they overlooked the
contributions of many other African American
soldiers during World War II.
For instance, the U.S. military awarded the
Medal of Honor—the highest honor that can
be awarded to a serviceman or –woman—a
total of 464 times due to the conflict in
World War II with 324 being awarded to soldiers
in the Army.
None of those soldiers were African American,
and the racial bias continued with other awards.
The awards eventually trickled in for Fox
though.
In 1982, some 38 years after being nominated,
he was finally awarded the Distinguished Service
Cross.
Next up, research conducted by Shaw University
in North Carolina, commissioned by the U.S.
Army, worked to uncover whether or not African
American soldiers had been unfairly denied
the Medal of Honor.
The results were that, “Shaw’s team…
recommended the Army consider a group of 10
soldiers for the Medal of Honor.”
Lt. Fox was among those soldiers recommended,
seven of which were ultimately chosen, and
six of which were posthumously awarded the
medal by President Bill Clinton in 1997.
(One, Vernon Baker, was still alive to accept
his award in person.)
As for Fox, his medal was accepted by his
widow, Arlene Marrow.
Captain America may have jumped on a fake
grenade to save his fellow soldiers in training,
but in real life Lance Corporal William Kyle
Carpenter actually did this… only the grenade
was real.
On November 21, 2010 while in Afghanistan,
a grenade was thrown into his sandbagged position.
Rather than run, he used his own body to shield
the single other soldier with him from the
blast.
Miraculously, though severely injured, Carpenter
lived and was awarded the Medal of Honor in
June
of 2014.